levron pas de transports en commun des
services publics en souffrance une vraie
communes rurales où le taux de retraités
est important le maire a donc décidé
d'ouvrir un cahier de doléances
je pense qu'il était indispensable
d'accompagner un mouvement spontané de
revendication de de gens qui se sentent
mal à l'aise dans notre pays
sans surprise c'est la situation
économique et en particulier des
retraités qui est arrivé en tête des
réponses comme dans le département où
sur 189 témoignages 74 se réfère à la
justice sociale
mais comme les chiffres en témoignent
rares sont ceux qui se sont déplacés
on a rencontré sept ou huit personnes
mais je pense que maintenant le
mouvement va s'amplifier du fait que le
gouvernement va lancer cette fameuse
campagne de d1 doléances qui doit durer
deux mois
montierchaume presque la ville à la
campagne pour les quelques 1800
habitants qui la composent des actifs
plus nombreux qu à levroux une proximité
avec châteauroux plus grande mais des
services publics en berne et le même
sentiment d'abandon la dizaine de
témoignages écrits recueillis en
attestent
c'est la cgc des retraites c'est la
crainte pour les petits-enfants et les
enfants c'est le problème du désert
médical
c'est le problème des services services
publics qui sont euros le maire est très
sollicitée par ses administrés notamment
sur l'organisation du grand débat
national
ils sont très intéressés et ce qu'ils
veulent pas se faire berner
alors ce que je pense que là il ne faut
pas que derrière rien s'il n'ya pas de
réponse je pense que le mouvement peut
s'amplifier
c'est une crainte dans l'indre la
justice fiscale a fait l'objet de 61
témoignage avant l'organisation
territoriale et politique qui représente
une cinquantaine de doléances